one data point would be in every oecd
country so to the extent that your
economically Advanced enough to be in
the oecd then there are more young women
than young men with a college degree in
every oecd country I think the last
across I think the last across the line
might be Mexico but um someone can fact
check that for me in real time
um but interestingly even outside the
oecd second number of striking number of
Middle East Middle Eastern countries and
so on you are seeing a gender gap in
favor of women in some levels
um but it's obviously not true in many
of the poorer parts of the world and so
the one of the difficulties with this
conversation is that the ways in which
women and girls are outpacing boys and
men are quite local so it's it is
typically in advanced economies that
we're mostly talking about and recent uh
it's only happened in the last few
decades it's happened spectacularly
quickly but it's happened very recently
and so we wouldn't be having this
conversation 40 years ago and we
wouldn't be having it still probably
half the countries in the world sure
what is redshirts in
red shirting is a U.S term borrowed from
Athletics which is to delay entry to
school for a year or delay entry to a
secondary school for a year so you
basically uh enter whatever the school
year is a year older and it used to be
done mostly for athletic reasons so in
the US it was very often done and this
is particularly true for male Sports
um but just being bigger uh and stronger
uh was going to be to your advantage so
actually you know being 19 is helpful
when you're playing a contact sport
um then moving everything else equal you
could you could get and you've got a bit
more time to train but now there's now
uh it's been used as a term for academic
red shirting so that's that's the
decision to delay entry into school not
because you want your kid to be the best
football player or whatever uh or rugby
player but because you want them to do
better at math and better English and do
better in their exams and so that's
really now the main driver of of what
this quotes redshirting phenomenon sure
instead
um in the book you argue of course that
um the differences between boys and
girls or men and women
um which explains the differences in
terms of Education
um
is at least partly because of biology so
what would you say to somebody that says
by insisting on the importance of
biology you are merely
um endorsing something that's been used
historically to oppress women
it depends
what mood I was in
so like so let's let's say I'm in a
conservatory mood and I'm at a public
event you know so I I'm going to say I
totally understand where you're coming
from
that is absolutely no
Etc the truth is I'd say are you crazy
like it like if I'm being candid about
it you know it's just you and me it's
just you and me right so I can only see
you I can only see you yeah yeah
like no nobody out there in the real
world thinks that there aren't some
biological differences that have some
consequences for things like education
no one who's raised boys or been a boy
or met a boy
things that there aren't some of these
differences the real debate is not not
whether there are differences it's like
how big they are uh in what domains and
how much they matter that's that's the
real that's the real debate and actually
um the problem with the whole debate
about male and female brains is this
kind of focus on adults by which time
most of the differences have actually
washed out by the time you get to your
mid-20s and going forward what that
disguises is the biggest difference is
in the timing of brain development which
we just discuss which does have
significant implications for Education
right so even if you don't even if we
can even if you don't think there's much
difference in male and female brains
among 28 year olds which there isn't
much difference
um and not very consequential sure that
doesn't mean it's true for 14 or 15 year
olds and there there's no disagreement
among neuroscientists at all the
question is how far it overlaps so I'd
say and the last thing I'll say on this
is the thing I find quite frustrating
about this debate is
acknowledging that nature has a role
doesn't make culture less important it
makes it more important because culture
is what determines how and whether and
when we express some of these natural
differences so to acknowledge nature is
not to deny culture it is to elevate
culture
um so in that sense it's not it's a
completely false binary yeah and do you
think the fact is that explain why
boys are struggling and schools relative
to girls
also explains why men are struggling
an employment relative to women or are
they or is it something different going
on it's mostly something different so
sure to the extent the boys who struggle
in education
are going to find it harder in the labor
market and especially now so so that
that's obviously that's a factor but the
main thing that's that's hit male
employment and male wages uh has been
external shocks to the economy so free
trade globalization and more automation
right and that's nothing to do with the
rise of women in the labor market and
nothing to do with brain development and
not directly anything to do the
education system
Etc the extent that we now need to
prepare man for this new world but but
actually it's just what's happened is
that traditionally male jobs have just
been hit hard by industrialization and
free trade that's the fact and the
question then is how quickly can men
adapt to the new world and so I think
that it's very important to realize that
things can happen at the same time
without necessarily being the cause of
the other so for example the rise of
women in the labor market has happened
at the same time that men have been hit
in the labor market but it's not but
it's not because women have risen that
men have fallen other things have
happened at the same time and in
particular de-industrialization
sure
um and do you think the struggles of men
in in the labor system
as one of the most important factors
that explain
um populism
I think that the the real difficulties
that many men are having right and
especially I think it's important not to
say this is not all men like it's not
typically the man at the top who are
actually one of those measures doing
pretty well working class men uh let's
use that term broadly uh the real
problems that they are having
uh if unaddressed or in some cases even
unacknowledged create fertile ground for
populist movements to the extent that
populism uh gets its fuel from grievance
um gets its fuel from reaction the
extent of this reactionary then I think
the unaddressed male problems are really
they are just great fuel for the
populist fire and I think we've seen
that I think we've seen like
particularly among young britons for
example quite a big gender gap on brexit
um there's a huge gender gap over here
in the US from Donald Trump's Victory
um the rise of the right in East Germany
is strongly related to what's happening
to a lot of East German men and so I
think that the gender Dimension to
populism is a strong one and isn't isn't
talked about enough that we know about
class and of course that's probably even
more important but but I think this this
gender element uh is huge but I don't
think it has to be I think that what's
happened is because we haven't addressed
the problems Square on in the mainstream
that's creates space for more dictionary
populists to to sort of pick up on that
because they're you know if you have
real problems that responsible people
don't address then irresponsible people
are going to exploit them that's a
that's a fact of human history I think
uh and if we're seeing that playing out
in this space now yeah but why do you
think the um Progressive left
um view this topic as a zero-sum game
um so they would say that focus in on
the unique struggles of boys and men
um potentially
um distracts us from
um being feminist why why do they see it
in such terms
I think that again in a generous mood
I would say that it's because it's
happened so fast and it's happened so
unbelievably quickly the UN updating
your priors
that quickly uh it's just really hard I
mean the cause of gender equality has
basically been synonymous with the cause
of women and girls for I don't know
let's say 10 000 years and has only
ceased to be so for let's say 40 30 40
years so we're talking about the blink
of an eye
um and so and there are many remaining
challenges for women and girls and so I
just think it's really hard
to catch up with such a dramatic and
social change I mean when you have a
situation where we've already talked
about the education gaps but you know 40
of British households now have a female
Breadwinner and that's just that's just
I I don't know what the number was 40
years ago but but it's probably probably
quadruple it's certainly just like it's
just a different it's a different world
even to the world I grew up in you know
only in my early 50s so this is just an
extraordinarily rapid change yeah and
and I think there's a sense that there's
only so much political Capital to go
around there's only so much money to go
around right if we spend this on boys
then it means we're going to spend less
of it on goals women but what I would
say is that in the long run when boys
and men are struggling that tends to end
up not helping women either sure of
course of course yeah so we've spoken
about
um what the progressive left get wrong
about the unique struggles faced by boys
and men what would you say the
conservative right or do they get wrong
on this issue
well it's a couple of things one is we
talked a bit about biology and we've
just had a discussion where like there
are some biological differences which is
like a which is outside of like some
circles were like well duh and but the
right will sometimes then over over
emphasize those and so there's some as a
tendency I think to explain gender
inequalities too quickly by by result of
biological explanation that's because an
old story uh and so there's a lot of
nuance there but I'd say the biggest
thing is probably what um David Willits
once described as a tendency among
conservatives towards bring backery
which is a great phrase bring back a rig
yeah and the only thing I don't think I
managed to get that into the book that
was
um uh from his book about you know
generational inequality
um from a few from quite a few years
back now and what it means about it is
like conservations like we need to bring
back X we need to bring back the
traditional family bring back
traditional manufacturing jobs and bring
back whatever it is right bring back X
and I think that when it comes to this
issue too often what conservatives will
do is to suggest that we can bring back
the traditional family and we can't
that's in the rear view mirror now the
women's movement has successfully
created a world in which women have much
more economic independence which is a
glorious wonderful thing arguably the
biggest human you know the biggest
Liberation in human history and on some
measures but that means you can't you
can't put Humpty back together again you
can't you can't rebuild family on the
basis of women's economic dependency on
men that world has gone and so the
trouble is that if you just talk about
traditional families traditional jobs
manufacturing Etc what you're really
doing is you're just holding out false
hope and that doesn't help men adapt
what we actually need to do is help man
adapt to the world as it is we're all in
the world as it was and conservatives
almost always fail to do that sure
um what what does
um Hill mean
h-e-a-l what is what does that mean
yes it's an acronym uh you know you need
a good acronym as everyone knows but
it's a it's uh you can't get anywhere
especially especially in policy circles
without an acronym and this one is like
the mirror image of stem so most people
heard of stem yeah science technology
engineering and math interesting well
most people don't know is that it wasn't
originally stem when Judith Ramirez went
to National Institutes of Health it was
actually Smet
sm-e-t and she said oh I don't like the
sound of that I'm going to change it so
she changed it to stem and honestly the
rest is history
um we had stem caucuses has been a huge
push to get women women especially into
stem jobs pretty you know pretty
successfully
um heal is the opposite of that so it's
health education Administration and
literacy literacy skills as opposed to
math skills as in as you get in in stem
and those jobs if we talk about jobs
account for a huge and growing part of
the economy I mean a growing needs for
people in those sorts of jobs obviously
for teachers but also for healthcare
workers social care workers people whose
jobs are more on the administrative side
rather than perhaps the machine side
more a bit more relational
Etc and requiring all kinds of literacy
skills like how many you can go back you
can go back in time and find jobs we
didn't really have even to talk to
somebody very much during the course of
the day and those were very often mail
jobs but that's much less true now and
so those skills those so-called soft
skills are becoming more important the
labor market and that's where the jobs
are coming from too yeah so um how
precisely can we get boys into those
jobs
yeah boys I'm glad you added that and so
it's a bit of a vicious circle because
as those professions either remain or in
some cases become more gender segregated
become more female in orientation it's
harder to persuade people like my own
son actually works in early years child
care but but that's like it's very hard
to find male child care workers looking
at the numbers for the UK recently there
are almost no male child care workers in
the UK in fact they couldn't find a
single one in the whole of Northern
Ireland no one
um it's like literally literally none
and very few anywhere else and so and so
it's very hard then to persuade men to
go into it so you have to reduce the
stigma but the only way to do that is
there's obviously any good role models
we need male nurses and social workers
and teachers and psychologists going
into schools we need Outreach programs
just as we've done for women into stem
we've worked really hard
to persuade girls that stem careers are
for them we need exactly the same Zeal
to persuade boys and men that those
professions that heal professions are
for them but I also think we probably
need some more aggressive action like
some scholarships specifically aimed
that meant to go into those professions
just as we've done for women into stem
um
um in terms of because many young men
and boys
um will see those professions as
emasculating
um so how can we get rid of that stigma
yeah well as I said I to some extent
what I think we we need some blunt
policy tools to try and increase male
representation so there's a great line
like which includes scholarships
subsidies let's you know bribes you know
a lot of money spent on it and so on to
try and just move them get more men into
them right so initially I think we're
just gonna have to like throw some money
at that issue to get more men in then
it'll then it then the stigma will
lessen just because there are more men
men doing it but there's a great a great
phrase in the women's movement is you
have to see it to be it sure and so I
just think how we present Role Models
around that is hugely important um and
so just think about popular culture
think about the ways in which we depict
those roles actually you know
advertising and TV is actually more
gender stereotypical about professions
even than the real world is and I think
the last thing I'll say is like what we
don't want to do is signal
that these jobs are that are somehow
make them seem more masculine they
really are or more feminine they really
are we'll just be pretty straightforward
about it like nursing nursing is a good
career
um you know reasonably you know secure
Etc we don't have to sort of go
overboard in sort of making it somehow
seem Macho to be a nurse we just need to
make it seem not not as you said not
effeminate to be a nurse and so how we
talk about it's usually important sure
why do we need more black men in
particular to be teachers
well we need more men period yeah uh and
I think that's important um but we need
more black men because there is very
strong evidence that for black boys in
particular having a black male teacher
has some really positive effects I would
say it's probably true for Hispanic boys
as well in in the uh in the US at least
um and there are even fewer Hispanic
male teachers actually lots more
Hispanic female teachers not many more
Hispanic male teachers
um and so I do think a kind of if we if
we think about gender and race
you know you have you have to see it to
be it and in particular because black
boys
uh are and this is this is a big
difference in the US and the UK actually
you know black boys are the ones who are
pretty much at the bottom of all of
these distributions in terms of
Education they are the ones who are
struggling most in education and the
gender gap is huge so already for every
for every one college degree a black man
gets two black women get a college
degree and so that you know so already a
two to one for black men and black women
so uh the gender gaps are much bigger
there and so we need a concerted focus
on black boys and men in particular in
the UK the story is more strongly one of
class and where you see much more kind
of class class really plays in much more
strongly yeah
um with that in mind how would you
respond to the claim made by many people
that espouse what's known as
intersectionality
um which is that
um black women in particular
um face the most struggles in society
because what you seem to be arguing is
that it's actually black men and black
boys other than black women and black
girls how would you respond to that
uh well first of all I'd just get out
some charts and some data I've already
alluded some of them so well yeah yeah
if you're you're not looking at the same
data as I am I mean yeah you know yeah
black black women in the US are more
upwardly mobile out of the bottom out of
the bottom out of poverty than any other
group
um certainly than black men are the
least
um you know black women in the
breadwinner in most households I've
already mentioned some of the education
actually among Young Americans there are
slightly more young black women with a
postgraduate degree than young white men
with a postgraduate Supreme so there's
been this extraordinary now it's not to
suggest that it's job done for black
women but on most the dimensions you
care to look at you will find that black
men black boys and men
are doing significantly worse on a lot
of the measures we might care about than
black girls and women that's to me
that's that is intersectionality applied
properly because what it does is it said
you can't assume that the the position
of one group over another is somehow
fixed for all time right so if you if
you don't assume why Always above black
male always above female straight always
above gay
Etc because that will vary right it will
vary over time as to what that means now
as a general proposition we know that
those things are kind of mostly true but
then scramble it up and then add class
right scramble it up and what
intersectionality does is it scrambles
those categories and allows you to look
with more Precision than particular
groups